just elaine maxwell they're now saying
she could win
how can she win
there are five ways i like that someone
has
said there are five
things just lane maxwell can do to win
five ways just lane can win her child
trafficking case as her trial gets
underway in new york these are five ways
okay let's count them down because
um
five ways this social aid 59 she's
almost 60 could win her case as she
faces up to 80 years in jail on six
charges including sex trafficking of a
minor
okay let's see
scapegoat for epstein
so
she could claim she was being used as a
scapegoat for epstein well that's
a interesting
way to do it
okay
that's number five
number four desire for cash
according to pre-trial court filings the
four women who had leveled allegations
against maxwell have received quote
millions of dollars from a compensation
program set up after epstein's death
they're gold digging [ __ ] that's what
she's got to say they're gold digging
[ __ ]
false memories of abuse this is one of
the good ones one of my favorites
leading cognitive psychologist professor
elizabeth loftus is set to argue that
maxwell's alleged victims may have been
influenced by media stories and
conversations with other accusers into
creating quote false memories one of my
favorites this is one of my favorites
they they trotted this out in the 80s
the 90s
they go no matter what happens if a kid
alleges somebody abused them they go oh
false memories
quote her testimony will concern the
workings of human memory the effects of
suggestion on memory the mechanism
of the creation of false memories the
characteristics of false memories how
memory fades and weakens over time and
how memory becomes more vulnerable to
contamination so you can easily be
convinced you were taken to an island
and you sucked alan dershowitz's dick
even if you didn't
[Music]
right to a fair trial now this one i can
understand maxwell's team could argue
that her right to a fair trial has been
scuppered
interesting word i would have said
compromised by media coverage and other
scrutiny following her arrest after she
was taken into custody william sweeney
the fbi's assistant director for new
york labeled her a villain who quote
slithered away to a gorgeous property it
was fine
um
age of accusers lawyers from maxwell are
set to argue that not all of the alleged
victims were underage
her accusers are listed as minor victims
one two three and four on the indictment
but her team will highlight that one was
17 when she was allegedly assaulted and
that the age of consent uh in the uk is
16.
and the age of consent new mexico is 16.
well i still think it's going to be an
uphill battle
for her
but those are that's not a a bad way to
do it
get out and you say these money grubbing
hoes
are trying to get money
also
they are
not telling the truth
they have false memories that were
implanted in their heads
i'm being used as a scapegoat and if all
of that fails she was 17
which i love that's my favorite
they have false memories none of this
happened and she was 17.
so even if it did happen who cares
it's not a big deal
we wish her the best and you know how
was your thanksgiving was it good mine
was uh fine
it was disappointing you know i had a
bunch of friends over a few people you
know the thing is with these families
you got to get a real family because
these uh families that you cobble
together of these uh you know it just
you know it's fine but you wanna
you gotta get a real family in life you
know so it was a good it was good but i
you know i can't
do thanksgiving with my family and i
don't want to i have no gumption to do
that and i never will again
um i might get my aunt i've there are
certain people that i would invite
separate from other people but you had a
lovely time lovely time played golf yeah
out in the woods yeah good time
yeah i mean that's good i just i have no
interest you know in uh
in uh doing it but i think i have to
just adopt a kid and uh get married or
something because there's not much else
to do in life i mean we've been
relatively successful
with the show and you know touring and
everything like that but it's really
meaningless
and everyone around you is a kind of a
horrible person so you just have to get
another thing going and anyone that
doesn't have a family is crazy
anyone that doesn't have a family or
that thinks like it's uh
not worthwhile to have a family is kind
of crazy
because
these
things you cobble together from p it
just doesn't work you know you need
you need a family you need that unit
whether you're gay or straight or
whatever you are
pedophile
which is lane max any of these you just
need a family yeah she's close with her
family yeah
they're a family yeah
why doesn't seth rogen defend her
go what a boy is this a big deal
seth rogen is
this is a big deal
seth rogen goes i've lived here for 20
years
i've never viewed my young daughter as
an extension of myself
who cares i've never felt violated
what's the big deal
what that's what i mean it's easy to
defend like property crime because no
one cares about it why don't you defend
this
grow some balls and defend her like i
have
i've gone on the ledge to defend this
woman
and nobody uh will back me up
that's what casey neistat should have
tweeted
he should have tweeted i feel violated
that
that they broke into my car
and if we're gonna live in a lawless
society then free gizlane
how about that